well after a weekend full of
anticipation and teaser videos the
trailer we've been waiting for finally
hit last night yes grown-ups 3 is
finally upon us no of course we're
talking about star wars the force
awakens third official full-length
trailer so what do we know well we open
on a mass character that we assume is
ray played by daisy ridley and then we
see you're walking across a desert
landscape with everyone's favorite
rolling droid bb-8 we assume that planet
is djoko the desert planet we also see
ray and Han Solo meet up she said
something to him about the stories that
we've heard about your adventures he
says all of it is true so we think those
tales have been suppressed to a degree
that no one knows for sure whether the
events of a new hope and Empire and
Return of the Jedi are true but when we
bring a new generation in the old
generation together you know that this
is effectively going to be the engine
that drives at least the first
installment in the new series of films
we don't see anyone we haven't seen
before we may have caught a glimpse of
domhnall gleeson scare achter Huck's
during an assemblage of stormtroopers we
still haven't seen any surfaces
character Snoke the supreme leader of
the first order you know who DMC we
don't see Luke Skywalker and he wasn't
on the poster either so what's going on
with who that's the question that
everyone seems to keep asking themselves
beyond that there are some new aerial
combat shops there's a new shot of the
Millennium Falcon going through hyper
speed which is actually a really nice
bridge between the old effects of the
original trilogy and then a more
nebulous kind of cloud thing as the
Falcon shoots out of it it just gives
you a sense of how the practical effects
of the original trilogy and the new
digital effects that of course they have
to be working with are going to meld in
the new movie at any rate you don't know
if there's a new trailer yet to come but
even if we don't December eighteenth and
we will be in theaters and we'll see you
there
you